Jeff Goldblum returning to the "Jurassic"
universe! Japanese Spider-Man joining the
"Spider-Verse"! Daniel Craig breaking out that
Kentucky-fried accent again for "Knives Out 2"!
2022 is shaping up to be a fun year for movies.
Here's what we're looking forward to the most.
After more than three decades of regularly
getting new live-action "Batman" films,
you'd think there's nowhere this franchise could
go next. But the marketing for "The Batman" makes
it look like this new Matt Reeves feature could
offer something new and extremely exciting.
Specifically, the production's trailers have
emphasized a film noir aesthetic that appears
to merge the maximalist visual sensibilities
of Tim Burton's take on the Dark Knight
with the grimy tangibility of Christopher
Nolan's interpretation of the character.
Meanwhile, the film's vision of the Riddler,
played by Paul Dano , appears more like the
Zodiac Killer than Jim Carrey's over-the-top
incarnation from "Batman Forever." That's
good not just in terms of offering up something
different from older "Batman" movies, it also
teases a version of Batman that's more about his
detective skills than exclusively punching people.
Those promising concepts are paired
up with the equally intriguing casting
of Robert Pattinson in the titular role.
The "Good Time" leading man already looks
like he's brewing something special
with his take on Bruce Wayne/Batman.
"I'm vengeance."
Combine this cast with all the striking
imagery seen in the film's initial trailers,
and it becomes clear why, even
after so many other "Batman" movies,
it's hard not to get excited about the
possibilities that lie within "The Batman."
The 2022 Marvel Cinematic Universe title that
everyone is watching with especially intense
interest is "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
Ryan Coogler is back in the director's chair,
while the majority of the first
film's cast has also returned.
There's also new cast members like Michaela Coel
and Dominique Thorne, with the latter
portraying Riri Williams/Ironheart.
Rumors also persist that "The Forever Purge"
leading man Tenoch Huerta has been cast as Namor
the Sub-Mariner, who would make his live-action
film debut if he appeared in "Wakanda Forever."
A sequel to a pop culture phenomenon like
"Black Panther" would have always
garnered people's interest. However,
the tragic passing of Chadwick Boseman has added
a new layer of uncertainty to "Wakanda Forever."
Typically, it's easy to see where a sequel to
a superhero movie is going with its storyline,
but all kinds of questions surround "Wakanda
Forever." What will a "Black Panther" movie
without Boseman look like? What story
does "Wakanda Forever" explore? How will
established characters react to the sudden
absence of T'Challa? The shadow of Boseman
lingers over "Wakanda Forever" and ensures that
this won't be a run of the mill superhero sequel.
Considering we've gotten eight different
live-action "Spider-Man" movies,
it was only a matter of time before
the Oscar-winning "Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse" got a follow-up.
Currently without a name, it is known
that this installment in the series will add a
trio of new versions of Spider-Man to the cast,
including Japanese Spider-Man and a version of
Jessica Drew/Spider-Woman voiced by Issa Rae.
Producer and co-writer Christopher Miller teased
last year on Twitter that the sequel will explore
even wilder visual directions than its already
vibrant predecessor. The endless amount of
imagination in the first "Spider-Verse" makes
the prospect of a sequel extremely enticing.
"Nah nah nah. You guys don't
get it." "Don't get what?"
While some superhero movie sequels end up
just regurgitating the original movie's
plot points again, the use of multiple
universes in "Spider-Verse" inherently
means there are limitless possibilities
for the tales this film could explore.
It'll also be interesting to see if this
sequel ends up building on the post-credits
scene of the first "Spider-Verse," which not only
introduced Spider-Man 2099 (voiced by Oscar Isaac)
but outfitted him with a watch that allowed
him to travel between dimensions with ease.
Those dinosaurs are stomping back into movie
theaters next summer with "Jurassic World:
Dominion," which will follow up
on the events of "Jurassic World:
Fallen Kingdom" and take place in a world
where dinosaurs now roam free in America.
Exact plot details are being
kept under lock and key,
but it's known that the cast for
"Dominion" will include original
"Jurassic Park" leads Sam Neill, Laura Dern,
and Jeff Goldblum reprising their roles.
The return of this trio is already
enough to get "Jurassic Park" fans
stoked to see "Dominion," but moviegoers
should also get excited about newcomer cast
members like Mamoudou Athie and who promise
to inject new personality into this series.
For those who think this franchise has
gone extinct, "Jurassic World: Dominion"
certainly has the potential to show that life,
or at least a jolt of creativity, finds a way.
Can you believe it's been 25 years since the
original "Mission: Impossible" lit the fuse
and blew up everyone's expectations for what
a movie adaptation of an old TV show could be?
"So hard to keep track of these things."
Rather than leaning on fan-service and
hollow rehashes of familiar storylines
from its source material, the "Mission:
Impossible" series keeps on delivering
fresh new stunts and exciting storylines that
keep moviegoers across the globe guessing.
With all these achievements under the
franchise's belt, no wonder people are
so excited to see what lies in store for
Ethan Hunt in "Mission: Impossible 7."
There are also lots of new cast members
joining this particular adventure.
Esai Morales is onboard to play the primary
villain, while Hayley Atwell is portraying
someone described on the "Light The Fuse"
podcast as a "destructive force of nature."
As if those two weren't enough, Shea Whigham, Pom
Klementieff and Cary Elwes, among many others, are
also taking on new characters in this sprawling
series. Then, of course, there are the stunts,
which apparently include Cruise riding a dirt
bike off a cliff. What more could you want?
For years, Aquaman was a punchline, but the 2018
"Aquaman" movie became a surprise monster hit,
grossing $1.14 billion worldwide and securing
the title of highest-grossing DC Comics
adaptation at the worldwide box office.
All eyes are now on the film's sequel,
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom," to see if the
momentum behind this character can be maintained.
"I'm no leader. I'm not a king. I do
not work or play well with others."
James Wan is back in the director's chair
for this installment and both Jason Momoa
and Amber Heard are returning. Yahya
Abdul-Mateen II is also coming back in
a much more prominent capacity as the
supervillain David Kane/Black Manta.
It's nice to know there's a capable cast involved,
but what people really want out of an "Aquaman"
movie is all the staggering spectacle its
predecessor delivered. If Wan can deliver on that,
then Aquaman won't ever have to worry
about being reduced to a punchline again.
"Avatar" debuted back in 2009 and did huge
numbers. Usually, a movie that impacts the
global box office like that James Cameron epic
will receive a barrage of sequels in short order.
But Cameron has taken his time in
crafting follow-ups to "Avatar,"
which has resulted in countless release
date delays even before the COVID-19
pandemic threw a wrench into the
production of all four sequels.
The first of these sequels is set for a December
2022 release and, even after all this waiting,
the world of Pandora still seems surprisingly
intriguing. For one thing, Cameron is good at
creating cinematic spectacles, period. Second,
projects like "Aliens" and "Terminator 2: Judgment
Day" show that Cameron knows how to make sequels
that just aren't hollow rehashes of the past.
The extensive wait between the original
"Avatar" and the first of its sequels
also gives one hope that Cameron and company have
spent that time wisely to make this
blockbuster as good as it can be.
No one knows if the world is still craving more
"Avatar" like it was in 2009, but the reputation
of Cameron ensures that "Avatar 2" is one of the
most intriguing cinematic question marks of 2022.
One good murder mystery deserves another, so
Benoit Blanc is back. After "Knives Out" became
a smash, it was only inevitable that the world
would be greeted with further Blanc adventures.
Classic sleuths like Hercule Poirot got
called back for countless further mysteries,
so why shouldn't Blanc also solve an
endless series of eccentric cases?
"My presence will be ornamental."
Daniel Craig is the only returning
cast member for this sequel, a welcome
indicator that this follow-up doesn't intend
to just play like a rerun of its predecessor.
"Knives Out 2" has assembled a crop of brand
new famous faces for Blanc to contend with,
from Dave Bautista to Kathryn Hahn to Ethan Hawke.
It isn't just in the cast that "Knives
Out 2" hopes to deliver something fresh:
An international backdrop also promises to
differentiate this follow-up from its predecessor,
as does a Netflix premiere
instead of a theatrical release.
If you thought the "Toy Story" saga
came to an end with "Toy Story 4,"
think again. "Lightyear" is the newest
entry in this franchise and delivers to
moviegoers the original story that
the Buzz Lightyear toy is based on.
That's an elaborate set-up for what appears
to be Pixar's attempt at doing a more jovial
sci-fi film after delivering a weightier
take on the genre with the 2008 feature
"WALL-E." It also allows the toy division
of Disney to sell a whole new army of Buzz
Lightyear toys to kids worldwide, which
is never a bad thing for the Mouse House.
"Lightyear" doesn't sound like
an essential movie on paper,
but Pixar's been rolling nothing but
aces when it comes to the "Toy Story"
franchise. Even after "Toy Story 3" seemed to
conclude the saga on a perfect note, "Toy Story
4" managed to deliver a poignant epilogue for the
story of Woody the Cowboy. If it lives up to its
potential, "Lightyear" could prove to be a worthy
return to the "Toy Story" universe after all.
It's been a while since South Korean cinema legend
Park Chan-wook delivered a new feature film to
movie theaters. His last film, the captivatingly
twisty "The Handmaiden," was one of his very best
works, making the wait for his next motion
picture all the more difficult to endure.
However, this master of unpredictable
cinema like "Oldboy" appears poised to
finally return to the big screen with
his new feature, "Decision to Leave."
The scant plot details that have been
revealed indicate that "Decision to
Leave" follows a detective who gets embroiled
in a romance with a murder suspect. However,
this is one movie where the director is
reason enough to keep an eye on a project.
It's been too long since a twisted new vision from
director David Cronenberg arrived in theaters.
The body horror auteur behind
projects ranging from "Scanners"
to "A History of Violence" is
responsible for some of the most
unsettling storylines and images ever
to exist in the medium of cinema.
Now it appears Cronenberg will have an opportunity
to add another sterling effort to his filmography
with the 2022 movie "Crimes of the Future." This
project will serve not just as Cronenberg's return
to filmmaking, but also to one of his earliest
movies. "Crimes of the Future" is a remake of
a 1970 Cronenberg feature of the same name,
only his second directorial effort at the time.
Comments from Viggo Mortensen to GQ about
the project indicate that anyone expecting
a mere shot-for-shot remake of an
old feature needs to adjust their
expectations. It sounds like Cronenberg
is brewing up something new and bold.
Having apparently already
completed principal photography,
it's only a matter of time now before the first
Cronenberg movie since "Maps to the Stars" in
2014 graces movie screens everywhere. Long live
the new flesh, er, the return of Cronenberg!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about new movies
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.